3x -1 ^ 7 when we get to it you can help
set we've got 3x -1 ^ 8 divided by 24
and then our plus C hands up for
agreement I get quite a few hands
tonight actually thinking hands down
remember there's a bunch of things that
all happen simultaneously here yeah this
index has gone up you can see the 7
became an 8 and then this 24 which two
parts of the integral did it come from
the 24 EMS excellent so we've divided by
the new index which is 8 we've also
divided by the derivative of the inside
function because what do we call this
it's got a name when we do this kind of
integral it's reverse chain rule very
good so just like we do normal trainer
or inside derivative you divide by both
of them thumbs up and you of course
could check that by differentiation as
you could with all of them puppy
we've got e to the X which integrates up
into EDX thumbs up you've got that plus
1 which integrates up into X and then
our constant integration looking good
all right now Part C is a bit sneaky
because you've got to decide what to do
with that half at the front and then
your index of 2 X so we've got here a
quarter a to the two x + C agreement a
few but not heaps okay hands down to a
few but yeah I less than a third of the
class let's say let's double check this
right again I commend all of you in
particular in these early stages you've
got to get good at differentiation still
so you might as well kind of come back
to this and check your answer right if I
were to differentiate what we think is
the integral okay hopefully I'll land
back on the question on that integrand
okay let's have a look I'm
differentiating what rule do I use for
this guy I used to roll right there's an
inside function there
it's derivative in this case years - its
- right so I'll put that two out the
front everything else just kind of
follows because having dealt with the
inside what is the outside function what
kind of function is it's an A ^
something we already know that e to the
power of something it differentiates
back into itself so this a quarter a to
the 2x gives you back a quarter a to the
2x what happens to the constant of
integration it's gone differentiate its
constant have a look at this does this
lend us back what we wanted it does
thumbs up so this is correct okay just
to close us off and this is sort of um
this kind of shows my hand for what
we're going through today the derivative
of cos x is it negative sine X hmm is
this too derivative let's think back
because this is uh this is not quite so
easy to save think about this right Shh
you're tough let me ask you this
question again when we started
differentiation we did first principles
all that kind of stuff these derivatives
here and the one we're about to get what
did they tell you about a function when
you differentiate what does that answer
tell you about the function the gradient
thank you tells and that's how we call
in fact as well as the derivative we
call it the gradient function so think
about what cos x actually looks like
that's cos x roughly yep just part of it
anyway okay what does the derivative
look like well you know there's a few
spots where the derivative will be zero
right which spots you have the
stationary points right where are those
stationary points at zero thank you
there's one where's the other one at
this dip down here and then there's one
more right at the end there yeah you
care with that right now between this
stationary point in this stationary
point is the function increasing or
decreasing it's decreasing right it
starts up here it goes through down like
on a slide right so therefore the
derivative in this section should be
negative right so it drops down like
that
when we cross this next stationary point
this part of the graph is it increasing
you're decreasing its increasing so
that's why you get this part what does
this red graph look like it looks like a
negative sine X to me okay so that's
great fantastic
and then lastly so if you said you knew
the derivative of tan to X he helps out
what goes in here to X what we started
with done so the two that so if you
identify where'd that come from
have a look have a look at the question
it tells you to differentiate right
inside derivatives - and then the
outside is tan tan turns correctly into
SEC squared private okay